it on your side tonight media use for
tweens and teens has grown faster during
the two years of the pandemic than it
has over the four years before the
pandemic began we connect with an expert
on how to establish healthy boundaries
in a world where media use is higher
than ever
we can't ever let up with being vigilant
dr suzanne barchers points to a recent
survey from common sense media exploring
kids phone and tablet usage and their
parents approach to online safety it
found more than 66 percent of parents
report that their kids have their own
handheld device and one out of three
kids downloads apps without any
supervision
barcher says we as parents and even
grandparents need to shift our thinking
think of website activity the same as we
think about putting on bicycle helmets
car seats
seat belts all those things that take
constant monitoring teens ages 13 to 18
year olds now spend nearly an hour and a
half a day using social media the most
popular by far instagram and snapchat
compared to facebook discord or twitter
watching online videos on youtube is the
favorite media activity among eight to
18 year olds appealing to both tweens
and teens boys and girls and across
racial ethnic groups and income levels
bartr says when it comes to any type of
social media and internet usage adults
need to monitor all accounts and get
passwords if you need help having to
explain why this is what she says you
say and you say
we're going to be in control of this
because just like we control
who your friends are where you go after
school
who you play with
your when you go to bed this is our
responsibility as an adult and we take
it seriously because we want you safe